this faculty housing of NUS can well
while we're given degree from the client
we envision it more than just housing it
should be a place where people build
community at the same time as an
architectural statement the outcome is
actually showing what a tropical
high-rise residential building can be
what we do is we try to analyze what the
client needs for example the use of a
firm concrete well we find that this is
a very appropriate finish and material
to use for this project and we did not
have to spend extra money over the
budget allocated to get it to be a
platinum rated building
we find that the budget would allow for
a meat market condominium but we like to
push for more space for the faculty we
add value by thinking carefully for
example we don't need to use expensive
materials like granite and marble
whatever we design we have to make sure
that it is is functional it contributes
and add value to the project
the present design a what is a cirrus
forum we're in instigate encourage and
promote good design nurture the local
talent
my advice to emerging designers is that
be true to your own experience and to
yourself because designers always bring
their own experience into their work so
if we look closely at who we are where
we live our own culture over time we
should be able to create something
that's unique and speaks of where we
live where we come from stay true to
your dreams stay on course this is can't
fail design of the year
you